[Música]
en primera plana
carlos servando
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio francia internacional y de
france 24 esta semana con una propuesta
cultural apasionante a partir de varios
aniversarios literarios que se cumplen
en este 2022 como el centenario del
ulises de james joyce o el centenario de
la muerte de marcel proust a que en
francia donde también se cumplen 400
años del nacimiento de molière hoy les
proponemos reflexionar sobre el
papanatismo cultural admirar de forma
desmedida un autor de forma poco crítica
aunque su obra no sea entendida dicho de
otro modo existe socialmente un postureo
de quedar bien respecto a ciertos
productos culturales que uno no puede
decir que no le gustan porque sería poco
menos que un sacrilegio nos acompañan en
este estudio para hablar de ello isabel
contreras es periodista en la revista
literaria do bienvenida a isabel gracias
la escritora peruana novelista y poeta
crece a cáceres bienvenida y también el
profesor de literatura en la universidad
de parís esté armando valdés zamora
bienvenido ya lo ven la escritora acade
el académico y la periodista de
literatura tenemos todo para hablar hoy
del papanatismo cultural en primera
plana
se cumplen 100 años de la publicación de
ulises del escritor irlandés james joyce
una de las obras literarias más
importantes del siglo 20 asimismo
también se trata de una de las
publicaciones sobre las que más gente
miente sobre si lo ha leído
especialmente personas ilustradas
hablamos del papanatismo cultural que
según el diccionario consiste en admirar
algo a alguien de forma excesiva simple
y poco crítica y que nos emplaza a
iniciar debates sobre si existen algunas
obras literarias que podrían estar sobre
valoradas ante esto nos preguntamos
puede un libro considerarse bueno aunque
pocos entiendan su significado a lo
largo de la historia son muchos los
escritores que han reconocido que es una
obra difícil por ejemplo ulises y que
han cuestionado su argumento y como en
el entorno literario existen infinidad
de ejemplos en los que el consenso
general es más que cuestionable
repasemos algunas portadas inspiradoras
revista babelia el de la revista
cultural del país dedicaba uno de sus
números a ello papanatismo el decálogo
del esnobismo cultural este artículo de
la revista james magazine nos da las
claves para poder amar al ulises de
james joyce es el libro que la mayoría
de nosotros ni hemos empezado
entendido la revista cultural elephant
plasma en esta portada un poco el tema
de hoy con una cita de molière un tonto
listillo es más tonto que un tonto
ignorante bueno compañeros él es lo
mismo cultural isabel es un mal
contemporáneo la cultura es como una
especie de accesorio de moda que queda
bien
desde luego hoy en día lo vemos más con
las redes sociales eso está claro nos
por ejemplo si nos acordamos de yoga de
manuel calleja hace dos años por ejemplo
que era el fenómeno cultural de la
congénita francesa pues todo empezó en
el metro la gente simplemente se compró
ese libro y lo puse se puso a leerlo en
el metro y entonces ya todo el mundo se
había leído es el sexto se lo leyeron no
se sabe lo único que se puede decir es
que realmente el libro es un producto
cultural más como una serie con lo cual
antes a lo mejor ese papanatismo
cultural en francia
estaba más relacionado con debates de
ideas
y hoy pues en realidad el papanatas
cultural francés es el que lee el que
lee y el que lee mucho y el que lo
muestra el que lo muestran las redes
sociales el que el que enseña a esos
libros y el que dice que fue el primero
en leerse el último de michelle welbeck
y a lo mejor se ha leído proust pero
seguramente no se lo ha leído y lo único
que dice es que las frases de luz bruce
como dice mucha gente son larguísimas y
demasiadas comas y ahí se queda todo
claro porque el papanatismo es decir no
es solo además leer es también mostrarlo
es decir hay un aspecto de exhibición en
el papanatas
y bueno yo pienso como escritora que es
el papanatismo puede tener también sus
cosas buenas en el sentido de que no es
una exhibición solamente materialista la
cartera los zapatos los viajes el lujo
el dinero no en verdad nadie puede nadie
puede negar que hoy leer un libro aunque
no se entienda es una experiencia vital
es una experiencia personal entonces
aunque se exhiba en los medios sociales
creo que a la base hay una relación con
el libro que se mantiene que pervive y
eso a mí me alegra y si comparamos con
américa latina también muchísimo
esnobismo
bien materialista entonces en francia
sigue siendo el mismo cultural y eso no
también nos da a nosotros como
escritores periodistas culturales
programas culturales tenemos ese espacio
para
meternos un poquito y quizás
algunos de esos servidores y lean los
libros siguen al final o al menos sepan
lo que no les gustó eso también es una
cosa crítica el sentido crítico se
desarrolla más quizás le quiero
preguntar al académico por la percha del
programa de hoy en el ulises del
irlandés james joyce ya es centenario y
quizás sea un tema un buen tema
exponente del tema que tratamos hoy es
una de esas obras que pocos comprenden
pero que sobre todo queda muy bien decir
que la hemos leído sí claro una vez y en
américa la tienen muchos ejemplos
también pero muchísimos como para
visuales y sí claro y que si esto no lo
conoce que no lo leyó cuando en realidad
el 90% 99% las personas lo que hicimos
fue leer fragmentos leer partes pero hay
que decirlo porque eso forma parte del
esnobismo y también de pertenecer a una
élite porque sobre todo la pertenencia
es
diferenciarse y querer por es por esa
vía es sentirse superior o sentirse de
forma parte de un círculo restringido
similares no
perteneces a un grupo pero excluye a
otros entonces ese doble movimiento no
un libro sobre lo que eres no es muy
interesante esto me lleva a preguntarles
isabel creció armando la excelencia
cultural es por definición minoritaria
la excelencia cultural es minoritaria
definición lo mainstream
bueno yo desde luego algo que ocurre en
francia es que es verdad que si
comparamos con los años 70 y ahora
pues por ejemplo se ha visto mucho en la
crítica literaria francesa ahora se
tiene que ser mainstream o sea ahora
tienes que conseguir que la gente lea
entonces un programa de excelencia
francesa cultural como puede ser por
ejemplo la con librería en hong sang
invita a escritores de 'thrillers'
invita a gente que son más mainstream
porque eso es lo que hay que hacer hay
que conseguir el concurso mucho más
popular tiene que llegar a más gente
porque eso es el objetivo del
intelectual desde luego el jurado
literario o el escritor tiene que llegar
a mucha más gente para que se pueda leer
y tiene que compartir esa
esa excelencia entonces luego claro en
los círculos entre ellos siguen siendo
igual de cerrados pero ese mainstream me
da la sensación de que se ha convertido
en algo muy comercial para aquellos
intelectuales que antes se mantenían un
poco más al margen
[Música]
no podemos hablar de libros pero también
ampliar la charla a otras cuestiones me
gustaría preguntarle si hay obras de
arte que se consideran incuestionables
es decir hoy públicamente podemos
confesar que un cuadro como las meninas
no nos gusta que una película como el
padrino no nos gusta que un libro como
el ulises de joyce pues no entiendo eso
es fácilmente confesable públicamente
bueno yo pienso que
puede ser puede ser más fácil decirlo en
ciertos círculos depende de en qué
círculos está pero siempre tener en
cuenta que hay obras que son decisivas
en la historia de la humanidad que así
que han cambiado que han cambiado
las maneras de pensar que han cambiado
la visión del mundo aunque no nos gusten
aunque no nos gustan personalmente sean
o no hay esa relación con el libro tan
no es como un vestido o el color de un
lápiz del labio que uno lo escoge en
función de solamente su persona no uno
puede respetarla del lugar de la obra en
la historia de la humanidad de una
manera es como hablando hablando aquí
con españoles el quijote es un buen
ejemplo sea quien ha leído el quijote
entero los de todo el mundo habla del
quijote todo mundo que es una maravilla
que es el comienzo de la novela moderna
y todo pero casi nadie lo ha leído pero
nada nadie puede negar el hecho de que
el quijote cambió la historia de la
humanidad en cierta manera no es lo
mismo que encogen lindos el ulises de
joyce al alba interesantes que decir que
algo como las meninas no te gusta
también eso es no visto
es decir eso te pone en un círculo
todavía más restringido
y la mirada va a ser más hacia ti cuando
tú dices eso y entonces si tienes
preparado tu discurso y tú sobresales
contra la corriente eso es muy anti
moderno y entonces es algo que yo
conozco que yo recuerdo también un
ensayista cubano por ciento falleció muy
joven que tenía un artículo se llama a
mí no me gusta picasso cuando yo lo leí
yo era un modesto estudiante de
provincia de cuba y me chocó y después
me di cuenta que ahí había el interés de
atraer algo así no y no ya en el fondo
no había nada pero el gesto en sí es no
visto lo cual nos lleva me lleva a
plantear otra cuestión bueno lo estoy
pensando en el mundo de los vinos pero
el cristo se educa
a lo largo de la vida podemos educar
nuestro gusto en la lectura es un
ejercicio eso también hay que decírselo
a los chicos a los jóvenes que no más el
gusto no es algo no nos viene dado el
gusto hay un contexto hay una familia y
amigos es decir ahí hay productos
audiovisuales el gusto se va formando y
podemos intervenir sobre ello y es algo
decisivo yo creo en la vida de una
persona de este tema el gusto
por ejemplo en el caso nuestro
latinoamericano en parís el exilio la
inmigración como se quiera llamar es una
educación es una tercera cultura de la
realidad y yo no aparezco para nada al
que salió del aeropuerto de la habana
hace 26 años porque he leído me formado
y he visto que ha ido cambiando mis
puntos de vista estéticos y entonces
pero también en esto también hay por
supuesto un poquito esnobismo y eso pasa
también en una novela que te leíste hace
años que fue horrible o la tuviste que
dejar que con el paso del tiempo vuelves
a ella y de repente dices anda y eres tú
el que has cambiado la novela sigue ahí
es la misma no se les ha pasado una vez
isabel sí sí ha podido pasarlo también
es verdad que
desde luego aquí en francia y eso es
algo que hemos podido analizar varias
veces en el libreto la crítica cultural
ha cambiado mucho a lo largo de los años
sobre todo con la llegada a la
publicidad entonces algo algunos medios
que antes eran el papanatismo cultural
por excelencia y que hoy ya no existen
prácticamente pues eso también ha
cambiado mucho la figura del papanatas
por decirlo así es decir que hoy en día
los críticos literarios en francia no
critican siempre hacen críticas pero
suelen ser positivas y cuando no les
gusta les cuesta los intereses
comerciales son muchísimo más evidentes
hoy entonces ese es a esa figura del
papanatas que podía a lo mejor pues a lo
mejor podía en una época en de los años
60-70 más política a lo mejor tenía otra
aura hoy en día pues ya no la encarna de
la misma manera
y es
la verdad es que a mí me choca la
cantidad de gente que presume de
simplemente leer leer mucho ya no
solamente ayoví sua proust pero leer
leer un libro y bueno ahí cuando un poco
pena hay más difícil de ser papanatas
hoy en día mismo es más difícil y yo
creo que es necesite antes y también hay
registros hay más cobre que por ejemplo
yo creo que la persona que más lee no es
por ejemplo alguien como como yo un
profesor sino es el ciudadano medio que
consume lo que se llama literatura de
aeropuerto que va a salir en tren y
compra un libro y esa persona yo lo sé
por experiencia porque veo muchas
personas así que me dicen un título por
ejemplo yo no sé qué está hablando por
un libro reciente y esa persona no tiene
ningún compromiso profesional está
leyendo porque lo vio en la prensa y no
va a consumir pero ahora permiten que
haga una pausa en estos momentos está
muy interesante lo que estamos hablando
lo vamos a continuar haciendo en unos
instantes aquí en primera plana esta
hora
[Música]
france24 su ventana al mundo
liberté égalité actual y ti
continuamos en primera plana esta semana
hablando de esnobismo cultural o de
papanatismo nos acompañan para ello la
periodista isabel contreras la escritora
grecia cáceres y el profesor de
literatura armando valdez antes de irnos
a pausa es creo que estaba diciendo en
grecia que es más difícil ser papanatas
hoy en día no si es más difícil porque
bueno la se ha ampliado mucho tenemos
esta cultura popular que sea que se ha
vuelto menos restrictiva pienso yo como
decía unos antes también claro en la
vida hay ventajas inconvenientes que
hace toda la vida son los grises no hay
no es todo blanco ni negro es todo muy
matizable verdad o blanco ni negro pero
tenemos que preguntarnos también al
fondo qué cosa es la literatura para
nosotros no hablar es la manera del
libro como tú decías es un accesorio o
es una experiencia vital y nadie va a
poder comprarte nunca la experiencia de
haber leído el joyce por ejemplo es
imposible de comprar entonces estamos
fuera de al mismo tema estamos dentro de
un mercado que es muy importante y que
se ha abierto mucho a la literatura
popular porque siento que ofrece son muy
snob y todo lo que era lo policía
y todo lo que era la literatura rosa de
todo lo que era el don de cine todo eso
era visto un poco así de costado y ahora
su entrado también con mucho con la
entrada de la literatura femenina la
literatura femenina ha abierto también
un montón de temáticas que son más
ligadas a la vida de todos los días
entonces pues ha abierto no entonces ahí
hay una posición un poco un poco más
abierta entonces y como decía armando
decir que no te gusta algo casi se ha
vuelto una nueva manera de esnobismo
quizás habría que pensar eso también no
el esnobismo del esnobismo vale y les
voy a leer una definición de esnobismo
cultural que hizo el dramaturgo español
albert boadella el esnobismo cultural es
eso que ha posibilitado que se expongan
excrementos como obras de arte están de
acuerdo que les parece como decíamos a
su momento es que hay un mercado es
decir el mercado se construye en la
manía que se compra y entonces se hace
creer eso yo yo creo que todos hemos
vivido eso en un salón de arte
contemporáneo que tú estás mirando eso y
está mirando al de al lado para ver sí
si no hay una cámara oculta y entonces
yo es así es mientras existe un mercado
y se difunda se crea el gusto y se crea
la atracción cuando en realidad cuando
entras a la casa y 776 piensas que
piensas que te han tomado el pelo que
tiene el betis puesto que cosas y
entonces eso está con la época está con
la época yo creo que quiere decir
también que el esnobismo cambia con
respecto a un país como francia y
nuestros países de américa latina porque
en francia un ciudadano medio tiene ha
tenido más acceso a la cultura ha tenido
más acceso a la lectura claro y va a
consumir la cultura de otra manera que
en nuestros países donde con tantas
desigualdades entonces pues puedan ser
como un esfuerzo por integrar algo que
aquí pues es bastante natural si eso es
verdad que por ejemplo proust bueno este
año es el centenario pero hace dos años
celebramos el centenario de su concu su
premio con cook y también todos durante
todo el año para francia es una
oportunidad comercial el hecho de que
hay un aniversario eso quiere decir que
va a haber muchísimos más libros que van
a hablar vamos a intentar a llegar gente
entonces que lean o no plus al final
pues no es la prioridad el hecho de
poder llegar a todo el mundo y bueno es
una riqueza en este país hay que decirlo
porque que te guste o no brush desde
luego te dan todas las posibilidades
machacadas y bien hechas para que puedas
entender proust si realmente no te
apetece y puedes decirlo en una reunión
familiar o una reunión con amigos como
si hubieses leído las 3.000 páginas de
presna y
si
bien el aparato cultural que hay en
francia es muy interesante porque al
lado de la del centenario de pluses
tales pues las exposiciones en los
museos que son manera de llegar a la
obra de una manera más lúdica quizás más
directa y eso también te da ocasión de
hablar en los cócteles de que he visto
la exposición proust y que viste la cama
de proust y que viste los dibujos de
producidos los manuscritos de proof que
para verlos hay que ir a la biblioteca
nacional entonces los puede ver en un
museo entonces yo también admiro mucho
esa industria cultural francesa que se
exporta muy bien y que nos hace falta a
nosotros y que suele reconocer que
francia cuida bien su vida bien su
cultura y se hable es el software no lo
que le dicen
vamos a por más rasgos del papanatismo
el desprecio de lo mainstream el gusto
por lo alternativo aunque no tenga
calidad pertenecer a una minoría es
esencial para el postureo es no es
esencial yo creo entre ellos y en un
círculo muy pequeño muy pequeño
parisino por decirlo de alguna manera
pero estos últimos años se ha visto que
por ejemplo editoriales muy importantes
como calimas que son los que publican a
todos los grandes también están yendo
por la parte comercial no lo dice
se habla entre ellos es decir que ese
círculo intelectual es chiquitito son
esos jurados de premios literarios son
algunos editores de parís pero todos
tienen en cuenta que pues hay que vender
libros entonces para vender pues a mí me
hace mucha gracia por ejemplo que en
esta gone g1
uno de los libros de calimas es una
historia sobre una peluquera en un
pueblo francés que descubre proust y
entonces ahí ya tienes un enfoque que es
nuevo en el que vas a llegar a un
público muchísimo más extenso pero
tienes a proust tienes a plus que esa
figura tutelar de la literatura francesa
entonces están entre ellos ese círculos
no parís sino por supuesto que siga
existiendo pero ya no tiene ya no
funciona yo creo de la misma manera las
características del papanatismo quizá
tenga por principal característica el
elitismo y el intento constante de
definir clase social más allá de lo
puramente cultural hay
un intento de definir clase social que
yo creo que a lo largo de la historia no
es nuevo quizá no bueno yo en perú no
diría lo mismo porque
es muy interesante en perú pienso que la
clase social alta se define más por la
cuestión material los materialismo en el
consumo de bienes de lujo
muy ligados eeuu también a la cultura
americana
muy exhibicionista también y menos en la
parte cultural creo que nosotros en
américa latina las personas que están en
el círculo cultural es más bien un
círculo un poco de resistencia y
entonces el esnobismo cultural tiene no
tienen los mismos aspectos y yo crees
que voy a perú estoy sorprendida del
hecho de que todo el mundo sabe todo lo
que se ha publicado acá en francia las
traducciones están ante es un
preciosismo casi de allá no en cambio
aquí en francia si no es no es también
no es el mismo caso no aquí siempre es
la clase social de dónde vienes qué
cosas le es tener libros en tu casa
porque no los lees pero tienen que estar
en la mesa o sobretodo en los muros
y
se fabrican recuerden ustedes de los
libros falsos esas estanterías donde los
libros eran de cartón piedra y terrible
terrible
papel a dos libros empapelados que
parece que son tienes una gran librería
en tu casa pero no está
invitado
pero por ejemplo en la universidad
gente que pueda decir
pues yo me he leído todos los libros de
anagrama que es una editorial queda bien
sea bien ni mejor que otros comentarios
les voy a preguntar por lo contrario hay
obras buenas denostadas por el
papanatismo es una especie de pequeña
encuesta en mi círculo y me han
respondido cosas como la película rocky
o novelas de stephen king que les
parecen puede haber cosas buenas que no
puedes decir sí claro
forma parte de lo mismo
es decir cómo va a leer algo que se
considera malo o que se considera que no
tiene calidad y eso siempre existió y
siempre va a existir y por ejemplo
muchas anécdotas cotidianas escrito en
el metro y tiene mucho éxito total yo
recuerdo que mi hija un dios ha
preguntado iglesia no es que vende mucho
pero no es bueno
entonces jamás en mi vida yo por ejemplo
abriría uno de esos libros
las telenovelas las telenovelas en
américa latina cuando tú estabas
estudiante en la católica en la
universidad no hace decir que miras una
telenovela mexicana o venezolana no
y yo la yo si las veía en la vida te
enseña a construir también la ficción
con más cosas creen que hay obras
literarias que sólo se disfrutan a
partir del esfuerzo intelectual y eso
marca la diferencia la capacidad de
emprender ese esfuerzo es decir
también nos define el esfuerzo con el
que vayamos a enfrentarnos a una obra
literaria en nuestro tiempo libre y
hablar de esfuerzo y tiempo libre
isabel pues sí la verdad es que el
esfuerzo
en realidad lo valoramos a su justa
medida quien hoy en día cuando cuando
tienes acceso a tantas cosas a tantas
series a tantos libros a tantas
hay que hay que ver quién quien llega
hasta ese punto de
realmente el ulises yo también
creo y eso lo dice mucha gente que hay
obras que solamente se pueden leer a
partir de una cierta edad
hay obras que intentas por mucho que
quieras cuando eres más joven y no lo
consigues y gente un poco más humilde
que te recomienda que a lo mejor esperes
un par de años antes de leer eso y a lo
mejor el esfuerzo va a ser de todas
formas importante pero lo vas a entender
mejor porque la madurez estará ahí
el esfuerzo sea el elemento
diferenciador entre dos conceptos que yo
creo que se confunden hoy en día que es
la cultura y de entretenimiento porque
para la cultura sí que se necesita un
grado de esfuerzo
pero para la cultura este esfuerzo
también se necesita como tú si es un
contexto de aprendizaje y eso es quizás
lo que la inmediatez de la satisfacción
eso es un problema mucho con la juventud
porque además que van disminuyendo sus
capacidades de concentración por cierto
que la lectura exige ccoo de
concentración yo no diría tanto esfuerzo
como como ponerse en una especie de
de espacio un poco privilegiado en que
no estás ni en la vida normal y en el
sueño estás en una especie de estatuto
un poco intermediario y un poco sensible
a las imágenes que te vienen del libro
entonces es una experiencia muy hermosa
pero la lectura exige exige un ejercicio
es como la música es como tocar un piano
es necesitada necesitas una práctica de
la lectura y eso eso es lo que hay
tienen lo que hay que decir sin sin
asustar tanto tampoco a los futuros
lectores no referencias porque me
imagino que a veces no disfrutamos de
una obra porque nos faltan referentes a
ese es un
medio en el que se forma el individuo
pero para volver a la pregunta anterior
yo yo prefiero hablar de la noción de
placer lo que pasa que el placer se
educa y como cómo están nuestras vidas y
como tú decías ese es el joven ahora el
placer no está ahí está en instagram a
está en las redes sociales que están es
en su objeto terrible para un profesor
que es el teléfono móvil y entonces pero
en el caso en el caso nuestro como en
caso muy fundamento intelectual dice
y mi placer venía de releer no algo que
antes quizá no bien o cosas que no había
visto porque las grandes obras son
grandes obras porque siempre descubren
cosas nos quedemos con esas relecturas
muchísimas gracias a los tres ha sido
súper interesante compartir este tiempo
con ustedes hablar de cultura y a veces
debemos en los medios de comunicación un
programa muy interesante y muy necesario
y a todos ustedes hasta la próxima
semana descargaremos aquí en primera
plana gracias
[Música]